اما
بعد يقول الله
تعالى في الايه الثالثه
والرابعه سوره الرعد من
كتابه وهو الذي مدى الارض وجعل فيها رواسي
وانهارا ومن كل الثمرات جعل فيها زوجين
اثنين يغشي الليل
النهار ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
تفكرون وفي الارض قطع متجاورات وجنات من
اعناب وزرع ونخيل صنوان وغير
صنوان يسقى بماء واحد ونفضل بعضها على بعض
في
الابل ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يعقلون
الرعد
قران يقول تعالى وهو الذي مد الارض مد
الارض اي
بسطها
وجعلها ممدوده
مبسوطه لا غايه في الوعور حيث لا
يستطيع الانسان ان يقيم عليها
مصالحه وجعل فيها رواسي
انهارا وجعل فيها رواسي وانهارا
الرواسي جمع راسيه
والراسيه عباره عن الجبال التي تثبت
الارض
و كلمه راسيه ترجع الى الرسي في لغه العرب
وهو
الثبوت الشيء الثابت
يوصف بانه
راسي فيقول وجعل فيها رواسي
وانهارا انهار جمع نهر ايش هو
النهر النهر هو مكان جريان
الماء ويسمى نهرا لانه ينهر الارض اي يحفر
الارض هذه
الانهار
هي
موضوعه في الارض او مكان الانهار يعني
الماء او
المكان جعلها الله سبحانه وتعالى بين هذه
الرواسي وفي هذه الارض
الممدوده ومن
ثم جعل من كل الثمرات
جعل فيها زوجين اثنين الزوج في لغه العرب
يطلق ويراد به
النوع ويطلق ويراد
به ما له
اثنين يعني
يقال هذا زوج يعني نوع ويقال زوج يعني احد
اثنين فلذلك لك اتبعه الله سبحانه وتعالى
بقوله زوجين
اثنين لماذا حتى يعرف ان المقصود من كلمه
زوج هنا يعني نوع جعل من
كل الثمرات
الانواع
الكثيره يغشي الليل
النهار اي
يغطي النهار
بالليل ان في ذلك
لايات ان في ذلك جميع ما سبق ايات لقوم
يتفكرون وفي الارض
قطعا متجاورات
متجاورات يعني قريبه من
بعض
القطعه بجانب
الاخرى وجنات من اعناب
الجنه هي الحديقه او
البستان
و كل شيء لما
تجتمع الجيم مع النون في
ماده فانها تدل في لغه العرب على
الستر ستر
الشيء يقال مثلا الجن لانهم مستورين كذلك
الجنين
كذلك الجنون
لانه معنوي ر معنوي للعقل كذلك الجنه
الجنه الحديقه او
البستان الكثيف الذي يستر الارض من تحت
الاشجار
ف جعل سبحانه وتعالى جنات من اعناب
وزرع ونخيل صنوان وغير
صنوان النخيل الصنوان وغير
الصنوان
هو الصنوان يطلق ويراد
به
الشجرتين
التين مجموعه في اصل
واحد
فكان شجرتين والاصل واحد هذا اسمه
صنوان وغير صنوان يعني الشجره التي
لها تكون الشجره الواحده والاصل
الواحد فتقول ونخيل صنوان
اي جنات من
نخيل فيها اشجار صنوان وغير صنوان يعني
اشجار متفقه في الاصل ومفتر في
الاصول يسقى كل
ذلك
يسقى وفي قراءه سبعيه تسقى كلاهما صحيح
يسقى اي جميع ما سبق تسقى اي هذه الجنات
وهذه
الاشجار بماء
واحد ونفضل بعضها على بعض في
الاكل
و قوله تعالى
ونفضل كذلك في قراءه
ويفضل بعضها بعضها على بعض في
الاكل
الاكل يعني
الطعم فله سبحانه وتعالى يذكر هذا مثلا
على
القران
سبحانه بانه ينزل من السماء ماء الماء
هنا مثل
للقران
المنزل من الله سبحانه وتعالى من
السماء ينزل في الارض
وهذه
الارض منها قطع متجاورات
قطعه ارض بجانب قطعه ارض
تماما مثل ما ياتي القران على جيران اثنين
في نفس المدينه في نفس المكان في نفس
البلده احدهما يؤمن والاخر
يكفر
احدهما يحسن
والاخر
يسيء فهو سبحانه وتعالى ينزل من
السماء
الوحي على قطع متجاورات
وجنات
جنات عباره عن مدن من الناس وعشائر وقبائل
وشعوب وهي من اعناب وزرع ونخيل
على الكبار في السن والصغار في السن
والنساء والرجال والذكور والاناث
و
الاحرار
والعبيد
وكذلك حتى في العائله الواحده صنوان وغير
صنوان العائلات اللها التي لها اصل
واحد وكذلك العائ وكذلك الناس
الذين هم منفردون ولهم اصل
منفرد الله سبحانه وتعالى ينزل ماء واحدا
على هذه الزروع كذلك ينزل القران كتابا
واحدا على قلوب على قلوب
الناس ويفضل هو سبحانه
وتعالى بعضها على بعض في
الاكل في الطعم في النتي في الثمره سبحانه
وتعالى وهذا يدل على ماذا على ان
المساله تعود وترجع الى مثل قوله
تعالى ومن لم يجعل الله له نورا فما له من
نور ليست المساله متوقفه فقط على الاسباب
الاسباب موجوده قد تكون متوفره لكن الله
سبحانه وتعالى
اليه الامر كله فهو يختار يقول تعالى وربك
يخلق ما يشاء ويختار ما كان لهم
الخيره هذه
الايه
انزلت في قول
المشركين لماذا لم يختر لم يختر الله
سبحانه وتعالى فلان او فلان او فلان من
الاشراف لماذا
اختار محمدا صلى الله عليه وسلم فكما ان
ليس الخلق لهم فكذلك الاختيار والانتخاب
من هذا الخلق والاصطفاء ليس له الله
سبحانه وتعالى يجتبي ويصطفي من
عباده
ف نعم ينزل الله سبحانه وتعالى
الهدايه
على القبائل
المتجاوره وعلى النا
في البيت الواحد وفي المدينه الواحده
والقريه الواحده
والاسباب
الاسباب متقاربه لكن الله سبحانه وتعالى
يختار
يختار يهدي من يشاء ويضل من
يشاء هذا امر
عجيب كما انه يفعل بالنبات من ح حنا كما
انه يفعل سبحانه
وتعالى بهذه القطع من الارض المتجاوره
والجنات من الاعناب والزرع والنخيل صنوان
وغير
صنوان ايضا لاحظوا قوله سبحانه
وتعالى جنات من اعناب وزرع ونخيل الناس
ليسوا على
هوايه واحده بعض الناس يحسن كذا وبعض
الناس يحسن
كذا فهو سبحانه وتعالى ليس فقط يفضل بين
المهن المختلفه او الهوايات المختلفه بل
في المهنه الواحده والهوايه الواحده يفضل
شيئا من الاعناب على شيء ويفضل شيئا من
النخيل على شيء وزرع على زرع وهلم جره
فالله سبحانه وتعالى ينزل هذا
القران على الناس والنتائج تعود اليه
سبحانه وتعالى والانسان يعجب كل
العجب ان بعض الاراضي ما فيها
خير ما فيها
خير
ياتي عليها الماء ولا تنبت شيئا ولا حتى
تمسكوا
الماء وكذلك بعض الناس فالله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يعقلون ذكر العقل
هنا لماذا ذكر العقل هنا يقول بعض
العلماء
التفضيل بين القطع المتجاوره
وال حتى النخيل الصنوان هذا شيء عجيب يعني
الصنوان قلنا
شجرتين لهما اصل واحد يشترك يشتركان في
اصل
واحد
وهذه
رطبها اطيب من هذه كيف له نفس
الاصل هذا فيه ايات لقوم
يعقلون قال بعض
العلماء لانه لا يكون
التفاضل اما في الاسباب واما في المسبب
سبحانه وتعالى الاسباب يعني الاسباب
الحسيه او المسبب الله سبحانه وتعالى الذي
يسبب ويجعل للاسباب يجعل لها فعلا ويجعلها
فعاله
فاسب واحده ما
تختلف الاسباب نفس
الاسباب لكن النتيجه
تختلف هذا يدل على ماذا عقلا هذا يدل
على ان المسبب سبحانه وتعالى له شان
يختار كما انه اختار هذه الامه
جاءت اخر الامم وهي اولها يوم
القيامه وليست المساله
فقط
مساله من
يفعل فله كذا احسان الله سبحانه
وتعالى فهو الى الله وذلك فضل الله يؤتيه
من
يشاء هذه مساله
مهمه لان الله سبحانه وتعالى قد فضل بعض
الناس
حسا وقد فضل بعض الناس معنى وقد فضل بعض
واختار سبحانه
وتعالى فصحيح الانسان يسعى في
اي يسعى
في تحسين واستغلال جميع
هذه المقومات وجميع هذه
الاسباب لكن في نهايه
المطاف وربك يخلق ما يشاء
ويختار سبحانه وتعالى يفضل من يشاء وذلك
فضل الله يؤتيه من
يشاء فجاء بعض
الصحابه الى النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ضعفاء الصحابه فقراء الصحابه قالوا
يا رسول الله
ذهب اهل الدثور
بالاجور الدثور
للاموال
بالاجور اجور
الصدقه يصومون كما نصوم ويصومون ونصلي
ويصلون
ويتصدقون ولا
نتصدق امور غير
اتزن ما لنا الاسباب الموجوده
عنده فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم علمهم
شيئا قال فلا ادلكم على شيء اذا
فعلتموه لن
يدركوا اجركم الا من فعله يوم
القيامه قالوا
ايش فامرهم
بالتسبيح والتحميد
والتكبير بعد الصلاه
33 سبحان الله الحمد لله الله اكبر بعد كل
صلاه فريضه
33 فالفقراء صاروا
يسووها لكن سرعان
ما اندل
عليه الاغنياء فصاروا برضه
يسوو
فرجعوا الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قالوا اكتشفوا الامر فقال ذلك فضل الله
يؤتيه من
يشاء يعني الاسباب
واحده لكن هذا يفضل هذا بماذا بمشيئه الله
سبحانه وتعالى وانه الانسان يجي ويحاول
انه يجعل كل الناس على نمط واحد هذا اول
شيء لا تستقيم الحياه بذلك اولا ثاني شيء
لا لا تستقيم الهدايه بذلك ثالث شيء هذا
لله سبحانه وتعالى وليس للخلق ان
يفعله الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول والله فضل
بعضكم على بعض في الرزق فما الذين فضلوا
براد رزقهم على ما ملكت ايمانهم فهم فيه
سواء هذا شيء يعود الى الله
فانسان يجي يقول ليش فلان نبي ليش فلان
يعني ليش بنهاشم
فيهم النبوه واحنا ما فينا النبوه فضل
الله ييه من
يء تنازع في
النبوه فعلى كل
حال فاذا كانت الاسباب واحده فما بقي الا
ان يكون المسبب اختار سبحانه وتعالى
فهذا يدل على ان الله تعالى هو الذي يفضل
ويفصل يقول تعالى ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يعقلون بعض الناس معدنهم ضعيف
رديم يسمع نفس ايات القران ولا يرفع بها
راسا ولا يقوم بهدى
الله وبعض
الناس يسمع نفس الايات انظروا حتى يعني
مثلا الى زمنا انظروا الى الاجيال التي
جاءت
بعد جيل الصحابه نفس الايات نفسها ما تغير
فيها
شيء
لكن ما الفرق بين
سماع الصحابه رضي الله عنهم
للقران وسماع من بعدهم للقران
فرق مع انه الماء
واحد فهو يقول ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يعقلون وان تعجب فعجب
قوله الان هذا الشيء عجيب تعجب من هذا
الشيء كانه يقول للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
شيء عجيب صح الاعجب من هذا اللي بيكذب
بهذا كله هذا اعجب لسه الاعجب هذا من هذا
ليس التفضيل يعني هذا فاضل وهذا افضل بل
الاعجب الارض اللي تنزل عليها الماء ما
تنبت شيء اطلاقا تشفط الماء ولا تستفيد
منه هذا اعجب اعجب ليس الذي يسعى والذي
يسعى ويكون في تفاضل بين
سعيهما الاعجب من هذا الذي يسمع الق الران
ويفهم
المعاني ويبقى على كفره وتكذيبه بالله
والبعث هذا اعجب هذا هو فعلا
عجيب ونكمل ان شاء الله تعالى ذلك غدا
والله
اعلم الله سبحانه
وتعالى
قرر
الر the general
them of this chapter this
chch overarching
one
the
‏the
chap so most of what is mention in this
chap is an
an
تحيد before the prophets
andis and second all
‏another
ma الله سبحانه
وتعالى translates to and he is the
one
to and he is the one who has stretched
out
‏fl what the speaking
about stretched out enough to be
consequence
benefit is it completely stretched out
to where is
gl
قران قران
guid it did not come on
gey and so you find because of that
because of that
ambiguity you find that the verse is
used
to as evidence that the earth is fl
‏for instance many centri ag the verses
are used asid that the earth
is right the same verses
why because the verses ar really
speaking about that they're not speaking
about astronomy and geology and the
verses are a guidance to
mankind it will mention just enough
‏meys
mean of the qur toys that is a of guid
not on
gey سبحانه
وتالى and he placed in
it
mountains ly
‏m and placed in it a mtit of
rivers and he has placed in the
earth from each fruit from each
from each fruit each offering that
can be
eaten of every type
and every
‏variety he has made it that the night
intr in on the
day and begin begins to damper the
daylight indeed there is in all of
this
great
‏says which are right next each other
parts of the earth which are next to
each other and in those parts he has
placed he has he has
placed
gardens
and
some
‏and
harvest and
vegetation and gardens and
orchards of date palms date palms which
share the
same tr and
individualized ‏here is
that some of
the some of the trees the palms some of
them you know will be one date palm and
one trunk one day palm one trunk and
some of them will be two palms and they
share the same trunk they grow from the
same from the
or سبحانه وتالى ‏all this all
vary it
ised with the
same water the same water the same rain
comes down from
above yet we give virtue to some over
others in spite of that in their fruit
and their tast they t different
‏so we
have star
opposites have the sweet and s we have
the mild and the spice we have the salt
and
sweet we
have
these
come
‏even some even the trk
is this pal have a different taste than
the one right next to it even though the
water is the same and the trunk itself
is the
same الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتالى
‏about
the
the physical
causes that's
all الله سبحانه وتعالى
gu
spirit be
our
‏find two brothers in the same house
growing up in the exact set of
circumstances one of them is from the
people of paradise and one of them is
from the people of the
hellfire one of them is a criminal and
one of them is a laing person one of
them is truthful the other is a liar why
‏theare the bl dna and
theyare the
exa set of circumstances yet there is
that الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏back الله سبحانه وتالى
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
‏more the the same place the sunl the
same of circumstances and the same
water what is الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى
[Silence]
قران one will become guided the other
will become
moreed this
all back to
the الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏great evidences for a people who
understand people of
understanding ان شا الله الله اعلم صلى
الله وسلم على نبي
محد
[Silence]
‏ich
ا